Magnus could anything change your mind
to play in the world championship if the
former changes
I think specifically the games would
have to be shorter
if I were to let me preface this by
saying that I'm not intending to put any
pressure whatsoever on
feeder or trying to change the formats
this is just my
my thoughts and my opinion uh the one
non-negotiable point for me
um
if I ever were to to play the world
championship again is that
there would have to be
um more games and shorter time to close
and I I think specifically two games in
a day is
um
it's very very interesting and then time
control could be
for instance
[Music]
for instance in our per player and then
some some increments at some points
um so
with classical time control I think
there is
there is just no way that I'm returning
to the world championship